bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis dit
guillaume dussau tout d'abord merci à
l'organisation merci à quai merci à
nathan pour l'invitation donc les échos
alors aujourd'hui on va parler de mma et
on va parler en particulier de deux
salaires d'évolution du sport savez-vous
au cours des 12 derniers mois qui a été
l'athlète le mieux payé au monde non ce
n'est pas lebron james et par rodger
federer cristiano ronaldo lionel messi
non avec 180 millions de dollars c'est
qu'au nord mcgregor qui arrivait en tête
du prestigieux classement forbes conor
mc gregor c'est un combattant de mma qui
évolue à l'ufc
le fcc l'équivalent si vous voulez de la
nba mais pour l'om m'a d'ailleurs
régulièrement les gens confondent le mma
le sport avec le fc qui est la ligue et
donc pour la première fois dans
l'histoire combattants de mma est
devenue l'athlète mieux payé au monde
donc mma qu'est ce que c'est ce n'est
pas ça surtout ne fait jamais la blague
donc si déjà le mma il parle leymen donc
ce ne sont pas les mutuelles du mans
assurances non le mma c'est l'acronyme
de mixed martial arts en anglais en
français arts martiaux mixtes donc c'est
un sport de combat ultra complet qui
mène des techniques de percussion une
percussion à savoir qu'au point comme en
boxe anglaise cou-de-pied king boxing
coup de coude muay thaï aussi des
techniques de corps à corps projection
quand on va parler de judo on va parler
de mutoh 6 mai de soumission à savoir le
dj dessous il ya pas mal de critiques
qui sont très tôt et même un notam en
france la première c'est pourquoi le mma
se pratique dans une cage et bien c'est
très simple c'est pour on va dire
maintenir l'intégrité physique des
combattants
combien de fois on évoque son mail est
ce qu'on a vu quelqu'un est une chaos
est passé à travers les cordes il ya
aussi en catch pour les fans de catch le
fameux par dessus la troisième quand il
ya pas mal de projection et mes mains
pour éviter tout ça il ya la cage ça
nous évite de passer par-dessus
potentiellement de se blesser l'autre
grosse critique faite aux mma
régulièrement ses ne frappe pas un homme
à terre alors comme je vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure il ya différentes
techniques en mma le joojoo si jamais
vous êtes pratiquante je dis tout vous
avez tout intérêt à ce que le combat se
déroule au sol si on n'a pas besoin de
frapper au sol vous avez énormément
davantage sur votre adversaire donc par
souci d'équité on autorise les frappes
au sol et plutôt deux fois qu'une j'ai
envie de dire mais la responsabilité de
larbitre c'est de faire en sorte que
justement une fois que tu es un des deux
combattants et mika ou une et dans la
capacité de poursuivre le combat
d'arrêter le plus rapidement possible
alors on va suivre avec le mma tout
simplement là c'est une citation de
georges st-pierre dont georges st pierre
qui est considéré comme un des plus
grands pratiquants de mma de tous les
temps anciens champions des moins de 77
kg des -84 kg à l ufc et sa citation
donne un peu le ton de cette
présentation et de l'importance du mma
dans la vie de ces pratiques à leur
saint piat on dit vous dites je joue au
basket je jouais au hockey pourrait dire
aussi vous football mais vous ne jouez
pas à combattre ce n'est pas un jeu
c'est un sport mais c'est plus qu'un jeu
c'est un autre genre de choses mais là
on va pouvoir voir dans d'autres
contrées du monde à savoir le daghestan
que le mma vraiment le même à la lutte
et les sports de combat en général
permettent servent d'ascenseur social
donc la personne qui est présente ici
c'est la bible non magomedov s'il
connaissait le sport forcément vous
connaissez ce c'est devenu une quasi
icône pour coup le seul à avoir obtenu
bilan de 29 victoires pour zéro défaite
mais surtout à 8 ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il vient du daghestan de la
république du daguestan qui est une
région de russie et au daguestan c'est
extrêmement difficile il ya énormément
de délinquance il ya aussi un taux de
chômage qui est extrêmement important et
là bas la lutte le sport en général est
vu comme un véritable ascenseur social
c'est simple au daguestan il faut savoir
se battre c'est comme en france faut
savoir lire écrire enfin
généralement là bas au daguestan il est
indispensable de savoir se défendre et
donc le mma permet et la lutte qui
viendraient évidemment parce que j'ai
englobe les deux la lutte étant
primordiale pour le même mois parce que
ça vous permet de dicter de combat donc
n'importe quel pratiquants de même un
pratique la lutte et au daguestan
le sport permet si vous voulez
d'éloigner les enfants de la rue et le
mma les pratiques de lutte également ont
un
avantage particulier à suivre cette
discipline parce que ça leur permet
d'avoir un rené par rapport à les
éducateurs les coaches sont vus comme de
véritable mentor ils font des
pratiquants des hommes et c'est vraiment
ce qui se dit là bas le coach va faire
de l'élève un homme s'affaire aussi de
garderie plus plus si vous voulez pour
les pratiquants et puis aussi on parlait
tout à l'heure en fin au système parlé
tout à l'heure de football le mma la
lutte c'est très peu donné on est dans
une région comme ça qui souffrent un
petit peu financièrement
même si vous voulez vous avez de l'herbe
vous avez un pote ça y est vous pouvez
le pratiquer et aussi au daguestan on a
des programmes qui sont financés par la
russie par la république du daguestan
pour permettre aux jeunes peuvent
permettre aux éducateurs d'enseignés ça
donne aussi un petit peu plus tard bien
évidemment un mythe il aux pratiques
quand je dis un métier sa doublette en
combattant mais aussi en tant que coach
est donc là aussi l'état finance
directement tout ça est à la fois que
vous avez un métier vous allez pouvoir
potentiellement obtenir un statut en
france est réservée uniquement aux
meilleurs athlètes au daguestan si vous
êtes pratiquants de ma vous êtes
reconnus comme coach dans telle ou telle
ville vous allez avoir un statut
particulier vous allez vous accomplir
finalement pourtant comme en tant
qu'athlète et aussi dans votre
profession ou plus globalement
le mma la lutte également au daguestan
c'est vraiment un projet familial si
vous dites je veux me lancer dans la
lutte je veux faire des compétitions
internationales et bien vous allez avoir
toute la famille qui va faire corps pour
justement vous permettre de progresser
dans ses droits là-bas le sport est
capital il n'est pas aussi de voir des
posters comme en france par exemple si
vous êtes dans le tram à bordeaux vous
allez voir des poster avec l'équipe de
france avec les jours peut-être du paris
saint germain là-bas ce sont des
combattants de mma ce sont des lutteurs
qui sont dans tous les posters
dans l'eau compris donc plutôt vers le
monde occidental le mma ça sert aussi
comme potentiel reconversion il ya deux
exemples à s'écrire d'un côté le
monsieur l'adq un certain embonpoint big
hill des bois très absolument tout le
monde dans cet amphithéâtre s'appelle
daniel cormier donc daniel cormier des
au moment de cette faute en 2018
champion des moins de 93 qui doit l ufc
est champion poids lourd 10 ans en
arrière il était capitaine de l'équipe
olympique de lutte américaine et il
finira alain honorable dans le top 10 la
femme ici présente ses rondes arrosée on
a rasé est elle aussi présente au vieux
jo-2008 a été donc médaillé de bronze en
judo et deux nuls surtout en 2013 la
première championne de l'histoire de
l'ouest
et d'amérique a fait même une
reconversion dans sa reconversion
puisqu'aujourd'hui les commentateurs de
l'ufc gagnent énormément donc profil
similaire mais on va dire que ce sont
les plus parlants
le mma permet donc une carrière après la
carrière en tant que coach comme au
daguestan mais là c'est vrai aussi donc
aux etats unis puisque les héros mais le
fc
également pour les plus féroces
compétiteurs en tant que combattant et
là les salaires n'ont rien à voir avec
ce qu'ils vont toucher donc on va dire
daniel corner et randa rosa quantité
athlètes au niveau olympique en lutte et
en judo leurs primes au maximum pour les
yeux mon niveau aux alentours des 50
mille dollars en mma on est à 375 mille
dollars au minimum par combat donc là
aussi la différence est colossal vous
avez dit un million on parle d'athlète
donc on part d'athlètes faut quand même
être jeune parce que oui il ya
l'expérience mais aussi le physique qui
joue à l'ufc la moyenne d'âge des
champions est actuellement de 32 ans et
5 mois donc on est bien loin des 25 28
ans quand on parle de football de pete
physique non à l'ufc il ya même bon
d'autres champions qui jusqu'à 40 ans
donc la passe a permis aux athlètes
effectivement d'avoir une carrière après
la carrière et c'était aussi l'une des
volontés de la ministre des sports
roxana maracineanu quand elle a décidé
de normaliser de légaliser le mma en
france parce que oui le mba est
légalisée depuis seulement quelques mois
dans l'hexagone depuis 2019 il a aussi
pour elle la volonté c'était de
permettre à des athlètes justement de
pouvoir avoir une nouvelle carrière donc
ce qu'il a dit c'est le mma est
intéressant pas seulement pour au grand
public l'oci pour les sportifs qui dit
l'eau de la lutte ils auront la
possibilité de faire une seconde
carrière et d'investir un autre sport ça
peut aussi leur permettre d'avoir des
débouchés professionnels derrière et
aujourd'hui on est en 2021 c'est le
sport est vraiment lancé en france il ya
des événements quasiment toutes les
semaines et on voit de nombreux judokas
après leur carrière se lancer dans le
mma donc ça on peut voir que très
rapidement ça s'est vérifié et à terme
faire un terme d'ici cinq six ans on
peut très bien imaginer des doubles
cursus similaire à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui aux états unis où le mma et
l'ufc directement finance la lutte pour
se nourrir en fait des talents
d'athlètes
le mma une dose de réel là c'est pour
les pratiquants parce que oui bon là je
faisais parler des sportifs des
paillettes conor mc gregor des plus
grandes stars ce qui fait finalement le
succès d'un sport c'est aussi le niveau
amateur parce que c'est là c'est en
fonction du nombre de licenciés à peu
près 50 mille en france aux dernières
estimations
on voit le succès d'un sport dans la vie
quotidienne et le mma a un impact
considérable chez les pratiques on va
commencer tout simplement par
l'ouverture des ce1 ça vous permet de
sortir de votre pad exemple concret il
ya un boxeur c'est le meilleur boxeur de
sa salle il va se mettre à faire du m il
va se faire ramener au sol en pratiquant
de jujitsu train actuellement il va se
rendre compte que non ce n'est pas le
meilleur et arrêtent tous les sports
qu'il y en ait marre quotidiennement
quasiment vous allez être mis au défi
vous allez devoir vous ouvrir et
découvert de l'eau vers de nouvelles
techniques et surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le mma et l'ufc le
fc est écrite en 93 donc quand on
compare par rapport à la première ligne
ligue 1 en football c'est extrêmement
jeunes et tous les cinq ans vous avez
des normes révolution dans le sport un
sport aujourd'hui qui pèse des milliards
le sait a été racheté pour 6 milliards
de dollars en 2016 aujourd'hui elle est
évaluée
ligue à 10 milliards de dollars donc ça
on n'est pas aujourd'hui on a dépassé le
stade finalement donné chat ça améliore
aussi évidemment la confiance en soi
parce qu'ensuite vous allez forcément
savoir ce que vous valez physiquement
face à telle ou telle athlète ça c'est
logique ça vous apprend aussi la rigueur
dissiper ça c'est simple c'est
indispensable ça fait partie de ce qu'on
dit quasiment au quotidien aujourd'hui
pour apprendre ses devoirs il faut aussi
une certaine discipline la rigueur est
indispensable du fait des nombreuses
disciplines du mma et le dépassement de
soi aussi la savate soit parce que vous
et vous vous êtes mis quasi au quotidien
à chaque entraînement au défi si vous
êtes compétiteurs ou alors juste pour
apprendre parce qu'il ya énormément
technique et pour les tout petits c'est
ce qui est intéressant aussi ce que vous
pouvez débuter le mma de 3 vos enfants
petits enfants peut-être peuvent débuter
de même à des trois ans son coup ça va
leur apprendre la découverte du corps la
coordination mais aussi le développement
moteur qui est extrêmement important
pour la suite le mma ski très très très
intéressant c'est qu'il permet d'être
soi même de développer son identité est
aujourd'hui là aussi c'est au coeur de
nombreuses discussions de dire comment
peut-on défendre ses valeurs
s'affranchir du quelconque table grâce à
l'ufc ou à cause de l'ufc on peut on
peut s'accomplir et on peut s'accomplir
en dehors des ondes à dire des standards
qui font qu'un athlète doit être
complètement lisse complètement un autre
pour attirer les sponsors les choisit
trois exemples assez criant on a d'un
côté john strickland qui ce qui se
trouve donc à votre gauche qui évolue
dans la catégorie des moins de 84 kg lui
son rêve c'est de tuer quelqu un dans la
cage il n'a jamais été sanctionné pour
ça il le dit à tue tête et sa carrière
évolue personne ne l'a jamais on va dire
mis au placard parce qu'ils veulent john
lui il aurait dû être l'homme à 180
millions de dollars dont j'ai parlé au
début ça devait être le michael jordan
du sport mais et c'est parti mais il a
tendance à être incontrôlables quand il
est en dehors de la cage là encore il
peut toujours évoluer en mma il peut
toujours performant puisque ça fait dix
ans maintenant c'est plus jeune champion
de l'histoire de l'ufc disant qu'il
enchaîne les combats avant le titre sans
aucune répercussion il dit qu'il adore
la fête qui abusent un petit peu de
certaines substances mais là aussi la
droit de le dire mais ça ne m'empêche
pas de toucher d'énormes sommes et
d'évoluer dans sa carrière et enfin
colby covington qui va bientôt convaincu
mais aussi pour le titre pour la
deuxième fois fervent soutien de donald
trump et qui insultent bon nombre de ses
adversaires
la rossi n'a jamais eu de répercussions
dans sa carrière et le président du fc a
toujours mis un point d'honneur à dire
tout le monde peut dire ce qu'il veut ce
qui fait la différence entre un
combattant et un autre s'est finalement
leur talent dans la cage c'est ce qui
change par rapport à toutes les autres
ligues américaines qui pèse aussi des
milliards de dollars c'est là on n'a pas
besoin d'un combattant qui soit
complètement lisse non chaque combattant
peut représenter quelque chose il a cité
des exemples bien évidemment extrêmement
extrême mais il ya d'autres combattants
qui ont fait pas moins des fondations
qui sont de parfaits role models là on
est sur quelque chose de complètement
différent
également le mma permet véritablement de
s'accomplir en tant que sportive
beaucoup de sport aujourd'hui pouces
pour le développement du sport au
féminin on est même qu'on soit un homme
une fin on commence à 10 mille dollars
pour combattre 10000 dollars
supplémentaires en cas de victoire et là
j'ai quelques exemples qui vous montrent
bien que ce n'est pas rare de voir des
combats féminins être en haut de la
fiche et surtout quand on regarde dans
les chiffres par exemple celui qui est à
votre gauche toujours et avec quatre
combats féminins dans cette soirée là et
c'est celui-ci qui a été choisie en tant
que poster celui du milieu qu'on avait
un seul combat sur douze combats les
autres c'était des combats entre est le
seul combat vous voyez c'est uniquement
les deux femmes et enfin ça c'était le 6
juin 2020 là aussi un seul combat
féminin pour douze combats au total sur
la carte tout ça avec une audience en
mma qui est évalué selon les différentes
études entre 75% et 90% donne comme quoi
c'est possible de développer le sport
féminin sport féminin la première
championne est arrivé en 2013 donc il ya
moins de dix ans donc ça veut dire qu'on
peut vraiment développer ce sport là
aussi on arrosait dont j'avais parlé un
petit peu plus tôt elle des tirs elle
seule avec cet événement est un autre
les 12e et 13e performances les plus
lucrative de l'histoire du sport rendez
vous compte et tout ça quand on sait que
conor mc gregor qui est la zpg l'on ne
vient le top 8 donc on a quelqu'un ronde
has qui arrivés très rapidement espace
de deux ans est un véritable
raz-de-marée et elle a réussi à
s'imposer comme une star à part entière
du sport on n'était plus du tout dans
oui les femmes ne peuvent pas concourir
en mma est d'ailleurs le président de
l'ufc lui-même au début des années 2000
il avait dit il n'y aura jamais de femme
l ufc quelques années plus tard sa poule
aux oeufs d'or était craint
le mma permet également de se dépasser
pour les professionnels et plus que dans
tout autre sport le mma et
un sport extrêmement cruelle on ne peut
pas faire de pause regardez comme un
cador pour ceux qui suivent un peu le
sport si vous en avez entendu parler
récemment vous entendez surtout pour ses
défaites dans ses déboires en dehors de
la cage mais lors de son ascension il
était extrêmement dur par rapport aux
sports et par rapport à ses
accomplissements il n'y a pas de talent
ici est que du travail c'est une
obsession est de plus qu'il a développé
un peu l'extra sportif
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué pour
lui on a aussi le cas récent de clarisse
ashes clarisse ashes double championne
olympique de boxe anglaise championne
olympique en 2012 championne olympique
en 2016 et actuel champion du monde en
boxe anglaise wbc wbo ib fwb à chez les
layton de l'eau était donc la transition
a même à elle a commencé à faire
quelques combats et elle le dit
l'entraînement au boeuf c'est difficile
mais le mma est beaucoup plus dure et
enfin rapidement magnum donc j'avais
parlé un peu plus tôt qui donnait un
conseil à ceux qui veulent devenir
champion de mma si tu veux devenir
champion tu doit sacrifier tout le temps
ta famille tout ce que tu as si tu n'es
pas prêt à sacrifier ça tu dois rester à
la maison c'est mon conseil pour les
gars qui veulent devenir de grands
champions il faut aussi bien évidemment
un petit peu de passion mais c'est un
sport qui est absolument intraitable et
qui si aujourd'hui on a une révolution
vers le mma il ya énormément d'athlètes
qui tente la transition et qu'il n'y
arrive pas tout simplement parce qu'on
ne peut pas y aller à 50% problème la
sanction pourrait être extrêmement
rapide mais il faut vraiment si les
coréens pour espérer un jour devenir
champion
merci à tous j'espère avoir attiré votre
attention sur ce sport qui est encore
méconnu en france en france pardon et
puis voilà prochaine peut-être
[Applaudissements]